there's no other thing I will look break
the top of the philosophers they canot
answer it because why that's the only
options there's no other option for
example this phone either was make by
someone yeah or something or by nothing
give me another
option I'm saying it's on it's on this
hand but I don't know about it no
there's there's no there's no other
options except why is s Street s Street
why is s Street s Street was bu nothing
at the same time just making no sense
that's the only option okay for example
if you come home and your sister have a
child and she said to you I have a child
you said to okay that child you had into
you have a husband or you have
what nothing oh maybe Allah forbid she
had fornication yes there or if she
believes in God which able to do all
things all from God where is the other
option nothing which doesn't make sense
so there's no other options you
understand my point understand so
there's some things which we know
there's either two options three options
and there's nothing beside it you
understand so my point here is you know
you have a nose next to your mouth why
you smell food before you eat yeah you
have a you have you know the liquid that
you have in your ears is different than
the liquid you have in your eyes the
liquid that you have in your ear is
thicker the liquid that you have in your
eyes is thinner why I mean obviously
intelligent design you know but that's
what Allah said Allah
said Allah said within the creation of
the heavens and the earth and the
alteration of a day and
night it is a sign for who for people
understanding Allah said in the
Quran
is know the time for the man to think
once upon a time you not even word of
mentioning Allah you know you are a
living example of Allah's existence and
everything is around us that's why Allah
always said utilize your intellect look
at Allah's creation reflect everything
you understand it's illogical irrational
this tremendous creation come without
any creator doesn't make any sense yeah
I mean obiously I I do research like
here and there in every religion cuz
obviously I don't have a I don't have
anything against the teachings of
religion it's just the the like main
idea of God you know so that's why I
learn about load of religions I learn
about all the points and I because
obviously I don't have like a bias like
oh I like this one like this one I see
the counter arguments and counter
examples from from both sides and so
these people who believe so strongly
about Christianity and these people who
believe so strongly about Islam then you
both believe that each other are going
to go to hell no but before we go to
that okay Allah would Allah create us
give us Universal give us Universal two
Universal sound in it yeah let me make
something clear to you remember when we
talking about the options it could be
other options there
all is it possible for someone to exist
and ex same time no no okay it could be
other
option I would know I wouldn't
know are you saying it could
be so that how someone could exist and
exist same time yeah
I'm saying I don't know that I that I
know I don't know that I know so you
saying maybe it could be above my
understanding no but if you define exist
someone existent not existent so that
doesn't make any sense this what I just
said to you that will not happen here or
outside here or different world because
this called what is no by necessity you
see you exist on no this concept of
something exist and don't exist at the
same time doesn't make any sense
you
understand which we call it known by
necessity you understand for example say
to you look um is it possible for S to
come into existence without any creator
with
nothing but maybe there's other
option I don't know no not I don't know
is that don't know okay so you saying
there's possibilities in somewhere or in
some places that some can come into
existence Without a Cause
hean no I don't know no I wouldn't say
yeah you see that's it's called
Universal knowledge there's no other
options for it point trying to say yeah
so when it comes to that logically
trying to say you're trying to say
logically like when you you exed all the
options yeah because that's it and
called Universal knowledge Universal
knowledge which we call know by
necessity so we use that to deter to
look at Islam and Christianity in
Christianity if you tell me God become a
baby by definition goes uncreated and
they accept that yeah I've seen that and
the baby is created so you tell me
uncreated become created that doesn't
make any sense yeah you don't have to be
a Muslim to say you know what that does
not make no sense to me yeah I know the
Christians say um like uh because God is
all powerful he can be a baby even if he
wants to no you see there's two things
here there's what good is and what God
does yes God all powerful but there's
what good is and what God does good does
something that go that's what good is if
God become a baby that his own nature be
God because a baby's created baby's in
need of food God is uncreated God is not
in need of food so why the Christians
are mixing between what God is and what
God does even God does things but God
doesn't do
whatever God does Things based upon his
wisdom for example you can slap yourself
you can no doubt but would you do it no
no because what if you do it people
think you're foolish you see so when we
do acts an action has to be based upon
knowledge wisdom so Allah is all wise
I've seen those both points because I've
seen both sides of the argument yeah but
they they just Bree for they say bre for
you can because you can do anything no
doesn't make any sense us the Muslims
will say oh that goes against his nature
so why would you like this thing uh can
God make himself weak no no no that's
called sry question sry question for
example can God create a rock that he
cannot live this question doesn't make
any sense you know why the first part of
the question go and get the second part
just play with words real doesn't happen
you understand because if God creat a
rock okay and he's all powerful if
something is more powerful than him can
be same who's all powerful come back to
the main point the main point here is
when you look at yourself and everything
yes are you telling me this sunand and
the moon and you and the day and night
and and and the stars and and the Sea
and what you see all of this just came
randomly yeah okay so let's say even if
I understand that point I say there's so
much intelligence design in the world
and conect everything is connected
everything is so beautiful they has to
have in a Creator well then God doesn't
only talk about the world that we're in
now what about heaven and hell and that
will go to the let's say the hell
whatever yeah no
problem but let's say let's say for
example a Muslim now a Muslim can go to
ever eventually he can if a Muslim died
or put Islam and Allah will punish it
eventually will come out of eventually
likewise the FL Jesus those who follow
Jesus correctly and Moses correctly the
old no no no what we say islamically
speaking but before we come to that
because you first you have to believe in
God but I answer this islamically the
true followers of Jesus they will be in
Paradise the true followers of mos they
will be in Paradise the true followers
of Abraham you're saying the true
Christian which is the Muslim no we're
not true Christian no we you're saying
that the original Christian follow what
you follow now what you're trying to say
no they don't follow they don't follow
Prophet Muhammad that time I'm saying
people that follow Jesus before Prophet
Muhammad came the on of God the oness of
God and worship God according to
According To Jesus teaching for example
like Jewish people those who follow
Moses teaching and before Jesus they
will go to paradise okay as when Jesus
comes to them and they reject Jesus they
will go to hire because all the prophet
messers came with the same thing what we
say to you the other thing I want to
mention from the the physical world to
Pro Allah's existence that's which is
well known within us you know there was
studied at Oxford University and it told
them like 3 years yes and they spent 1.9
million yeah they spent 1.9 million yeah
they came to conclusion they took
children from different part of the
world they they came to conclusion if
you leave the children alone they will
grw up and believe in God and there's a
purpose for life you know I believe if
you took away if you rest the world
somehow some way people would start
believing in high being because people
don't want to feel hopeless no no no no
no that I don't this this
don't believe don't this Richard Richard
said because of the fear of the nature
you scared no because why I'll tell you
why is some people wish to be saved by
something more than them no no no the
something okay is it something within
them I think so who gave it to them then
I don't know it can't
be randomly yeah someone think think
it's like some sort of like no I agree
with that one no no I agree with that
point that we have something in that's
what we call F our F which is that's
what refutes atheism that will Evolution
because if we are born with it we are we
we who gave it to us yeah is the creator
because the Creator that's what call
Arabic Creator which we hope from God we
fear God we love God we want to worship
God we want that God to save us and all
of that no doubt you could say what said
said people never used to believe in God
when the the weather start changing or
and people got scared and and so they no
the point here is so they you are born
what called natural Incarnation to
accept the Creator you know I'm saying
you believe that the Creator's name is
Allah Muhammad but you you believe there
is God there is creation cre for purpose
and everything you understand and the
other thing that I can show you why
Islam is the truth what look at Islamic
teaching Islam came to pre there five
things Islam came to preserve five
things Islam came to preserve religion
what does that mean Islam paganism
politicism is forbidden so anything that
take us away from the true teaching of
God is forbidden Islam came to preserve
the intellect that's why alcohol and
drugs
forbidden third Islam came to preserve
wealth that's why gambling and interest
is forbidden fourthly Islam came to
preserve um Lish that's why Islam
fornication adulter is forbidden lastly
Islam came to preserve life that's why K
people unjustly committing suicide forb
these five things if you do preserve
them we have good Society the opposite
of that alcohol alcohol is bad for us
individual I mean I that's the thing I
was saying like I I try study some and
when I see these things I'm like this is
obviously the most ideal way to like
build a society that's what I'm saying
that's not Christianity though
Christianity allow drink
alcohol is the blood of Jesus but we
know alcohol even a small amount of
alcohol is harmful Prophet Muhammad said
lot or a little is forbidden also
scumbling interest is forbidden interest
is off yeah okay interest in judaic
teaching is allowed for the non-jewish
to deal with interest with you
islamically is not allowed with interest
for the Muslims or non-muslims CU
oppression is treated all right likewise
what they call fornication for majority
of crimes that takes place in UK and USA
is carried out by young people who come
from broken houses yeah I mean
destroy that's why it's called destroyer
of societies and the most evil one will
away from God because when you don't
believe in God and you turn away from
God everything become subjective yeah I
know I
agree like that and that's what Allah
said the Quran you know you know aism
and what's happened in the Western World
Allah summarized a for one ay Allah
mentioned about Phar and Moses yeah PHA
said to
Moses oh Moses who is the Lord of all
the EX
Moses
said the lord of the heavens and the
Earth and between
them if you have any certainty what does
that mean means if you don't have
certainty that Allah exists and it
should be worshiped alone you have no
certainty at all and this is the outcome
of turn away from God it leads to
subjectivity yeah yeah I know that's
what that's that's what makes me
uncertain because of subjectivity I
think subje so are you certain are you
certain in speaking to me yeah so you
have certain oh yeah yeah I mean um in
belief I'm talking not Isam we say what
we believe you know what it means we
believe mean we have knowledge and
certainty yeah but I mean can ask do
something in when you mean by believe so
let's say for example if I do a crime
and I know I'll be prosecuted by the law
do you believe the same way that if you
commit a sin in the same way that
you come
come in the same way that I know I'll
will be persecuted by the law you know
or believe that you will be persecuted
by God no you believe in the same way no
no I know for for fact you believe in
the same I I know that I'm going to the
law is going to prosecute me but I know
Allah said forgive me maybe as well I
don't set the question here sorry it's
um you you mean I tell you what you mean
you mean do I have the same belief that
Allah exists the way that I'm going to
if I do a crime that I'm going to be
no I I have more Bel I'm more certain
that Allah exists and should be alone
and Islam is the truth more than certain
that be I got caught up by the police
because I can run away C understand
so from the
police so Islam is so certain certain
about Islam because if I you know what
if you doubt Allah's existence but
therefore you doubt your own existence
but I'm asking cuz no no no a Muslim
yeah do they 100% believe or or this
belief is very vague is belief vague so
maybe sometimes you can believe maybe
you can even allow to doubt God then no
no no you can never doubt God no Satan
come to you no doubt about that I mean
Satan come to you to start doubting
everything you understand and the most
so Whisper Of Satan Allah want to hold
you accountable if you have a doubt then
the answer is in the Quran theah you
understand but what I will say to you
listen to this carefully yeah if you
start doubting God's existence you start
doubting you exist by by by default yeah
more yeah do you know why because look
what's happening now people when they
say there's no God they say you're not
certain there's no objectivity
assimilation the assimilation everything
subjective and that's why Allah
mentioned the Quran that's why you see
so when you believe in Allah say believe
mean knowledge and certainty then
everything becomes clear to you you
understand and there's many prophecies
that prophet Muhammed mentioned how a
man that existed 1,400 years ago who
couldn't read and write he was able to
Pro about the future in details yeah who
knows the future in details sorry who
knows the future in details oh my God no
I'm asking you who knows nobody know
okay so if you have
someone Jesus if you have these prophets
and Messengers who are who said they
came from the same God and they
prophesizing about the future in details
specifically and precisely would I not
give you certain they are prophet of God
and there's
good you would me if someone told me the
future you would think obviously this is
something about people something like
God yeah in detail no not prediction cuz
prediction I can tell you look I watch
football yeah prediction is okay so
Prophet Muhammad existed 1,400 years ago
he said will come a time when you see
the barefood Arab man competed in
building to building I've seen that see
that what is that okay another one about
the interest Prophet Muhammad he said he
said he said interest will become
widespread even if you are not involved
directly will affect you you know it
interest yeah I've seen this usually so
this there's too many prophecies to to
negate that Islam is the truth and
Muhammad the messenger of Allah yeah
that's why you should become Muslim I
mean I
think yes my sister I
have
yes one question very kind of question
no problem just ask it's
like if a if a Muslim can go to hell for
time yeah but hell is going to be
infinite yes that time in
hell it goes to zero it turns to zero
right
Infinity doesn't matter add as much as
you want to the timeline the time go
keep looking yeah but he's not going to
go Infinity person himself going to go
yeah it's going to be it's going to be
going to go time it's going to be
negligible time comp compar to going
forever yeah but I still but brother you
don't even punish for one hour yeah so
so that's Allah the nonbeliever yeah
there's no mer huh there's no mer no no
no no nonbeliever with the condition a
non believer who Islam came to him and
he turned away from it there's no mercy
for him on the day of judgment in the
Hell Fire you know why because one of
the great evil will turn away from God
because if you do believe that you going
to go in the Hell Fire forever and you
turn away from it so who should be
blamed should blame Allah or the
nonbeliever the nonbeliever yeah if they
believe they were going to go in the
house fire forever and they would they
would have followed the religion yeah
that's why in the Quran Allah mentioned
on the day of judgment they would admit
so what if I so if I because now if I
tell you what you have no excuse for
accepting Islam but what if I tell you
that i' I've tried to take yeah I tried
to accept it myself yeah I don't believe
I'm going to go to the alire do I say
I'll be I don't be D and you don't want
accept Islam I said I can't and let's
say I physically can't I I tried my best
I learn everything I can how you try
your best not that because why you not
now I'm saying like let's say I tried my
best but this is a false scenario you
know why because Islam the one who
created you is the same one who sent
down Islam and it goes in line you have
to check yourself I tell you it Bo down
to two things why people don't accept
Islam to two factors either is a
psychological factor or a social Factor
psychological Factor he's arrogant one
of them or he's he desires some things
which he knows by Islam will not do it
or he by social Factor he's scared that
plan people look down on him or his
family gu him because no doubt Allah
creat us he create us in a way that our
sound reasoning our natural ination if
is left alone there's no outside any
outside factors affecting it or
misleading it will accept Islam that's
why that's why the fastest grow in
religion on the face of the Earth what
is it Islam even though watch this yeah
to show you even though there's a huge
war against Islam on the on the
mainstream media so imagine there's many
barriers to stop Islam
accept there's too many barriers from
stopping people accepting Islam but yet
Islam is the fastest growing religion in
the Western World when there's the huge
war against Islam on the on the
mainstream media the point here is why
because they see Islam go in line with
the sound reasoning with the natural
defination yeah I mean that's thing I
have most of my friends are Muslim I
have some
Christian Muslim have that's Muslim I
was raised like I was raised in like
kind of in the way of the teachings of
Islam because of culture as well it's
integ into culture yeah of course
sometimes you know even if you're not a
Muslim
but so I even try like my best to like
follow the teachings of relex the best
way to live I can understand that even
if I don't believe in God I that I'm
saying to you that I try I mean
that I accept teaching I even try in
into my life I accept God and pray to
Allah because I said to you I've never
prayed pray to Allah what say to you
what is stopping you look you have to be
honest all of us yeah what if you look
at this creation yes it's too there's
too many proes there is intelligent
designer behind it
correct so that's it so accept Islam
alhamdulillah alhamdulillah cuz you know
accept it based upon blind babe there's
too many of course look brother there's
two skepticism there's a praise wordy
skepticism and the blame worthy one
praiseworthy one for example you come to
me you say I'm TR you are trustworthy
I'm going to say no no have investigate
that's a praise worth but if you come to
me say I'm human being I'm going say no
no no I have scism now I have to doubt
no that's why skepticism that is based
upon Greek philosophy is a disaster CU
you doubt everything that's what it
leads to sry people start even doub
their own existence so that's why
Muhammad's teaching today four people
become Muslims yes one girl should have
to have something another one is English
boy okay aldah why and we've been I've
been doing this for the last 15 years
understand so there's too many like I
said to you you know we know about God
yeah that's why rejecting God and turn
away from God is a biggest crime because
there's two type of proofs for God's
existence Universal proofs incl your
natural inclination and the legislative
proofs which Quran and it goes in line
you see so why the Quran is for example
in the Quran Allah mentioned 1,400 years
ago we have made Quran easy to be
memorized now in Algeria Morocco
Pakistan Africa Asia Europe South
America okay around the world Muslims
memorize the Quran word for word the
letter for letter even though some of
them don't even know Arabic language
they don't know Arabic language but they
Quran word for imagine this book in
Chinese yes imagine in Chinese and we
don't know Chinese at all all of us we
don't know Chinese but guess what all of
us we know this book in Chinese and we
have memorized
it you don't know Chinese and you
memorize the book in Chinese you
understand that's one of the miracle of
the Quran that this book is been Allah
mentioned that Allah Allah
said we have sent them the Quran and we
will preserve it yeah now if the Jewish
people the Christians the Muslims all of
them decid to burn the scriptures so you
know what let's get rid of our
scriptures the only scripture with us is
Quran we memorize it and we can bring it
back into the written form you know who
can do that for us the Muslim children
the Muslim Scholars Knows It But even
the Muslim children so how a book that
that statement of the Quan and be
preserved and easy to be memorized it
cannot be a statement of a normal human
being it has to be statement of God who
knows everything about his creation
that's why say it's too overwhelming
also about the argument in the Quran
there's powerful argument against the
atheist like I I said to you in the
Quran there's a verse summarize atheism
if you start doubting God you start
doubting your own self and if you reject
God you start having no certainty about
nothing and why atheism on nutshell some
said not atheism mean when there's a
lack of of proes for God's existence
that's not true atheism on a nutshell
you tend away from God you have no certy
about God then it's you have no CER
about nothing else that's why now rape
Richard dokan said rape is wrong but it
could be right some people some people
you know we cannot say what Hitler did
Even though about some Hitler some stuff
which is you know anyway let's get mo mo
mo yeah you know cuz the people talk
about Hitler they same people who killed
my people you know anyway MO Mo was evil
Chinese Communist there or staling yes
staling did you can say it's wrong but
you cannot say object objectively was
wrong yeah yeah understand yeah
understand about um subc yeah because
you can only have objective um moral
morals from God from God otherwise yeah
because people say is M bad okay maybe
if you're born where everyone matters
it's okay yeah that's what I'm saying
does make it okay that's what I'm saying
that's what Allah
said
whoever turns away from my remembrance
from God's teaching you have miserable
life you and the highest rate of suicide
amongst who amongst atheist and the
lowest one Muslims Subhan Allah Islam is
a truth Islam is submission Islam look
Judaism to Judah Christianity to Christ
okay Islam not to Prophet Muhammad Islam
submission to Allah through prophet
Muhammad you understand and also what I
was going to say is you know Subhan
Allah when you have no good in your life
when humans are making their own laws
they contate each other for example now
there's off license behind us off
license yeah now if a drug dealer comes
start selling drugs the police will
arrest him yeah you know it the guy the
offli shopkeeper he's selling the same
product that cause same harm or worse
than a drug dealer in the shop in the
shop and it's allowed so why the je get
arrested and the shopkeeper of all Li
get arrested that's what Allah metion
the Quran that when the people start
following their own desires they will C
each other you understand another
one in schools colleges universities
they teach us we should not carry knives
don't rape don't cause don't do crimes
and so on but on the other hand they
what they call it uh um invite uh uh
rappers or singers generally speaking
who glamorize what glamorize rape
violence Glam look at the contradiction
you understand because they want to make
money yeah I mean I don't agree with no
no I understand now what I'm saying I'm
saying when you have no God by Def you
start following your own desires and
also that's why majority of times those
who are very hostile to Islam those in
power cuz they look at Islam as a thre
for their business like a Bankers
politians of course because they know
Islam comes for to save mankind
okay so what they're going to do because
they are rich they're going to utilize
their wealth to make Islam look bad
through many roots one of them is social
media thing is I have I I I
like and like I'm not like cuz I know
some people they can be misguided
because they don't know anything they
don't even know a Muslim fastor that's
true you're right all they see on TV you
have to excuse them yes no doubt that's
why you know and when I speak to people
cuz you know some people maybe they
scared they want to say something which
is bad on our Prophet Muhammad so I say
to them say what ever you like because
I'm going to refute it I'm going to be
happy with it no doubt but because you
don't know you are just saying it not
because you ha Islam because you're
ignorant so I'm going to be happy with
it but I'm going to start fighting you
straight away because you don't know so
I excuse you because you're ignorant
that's open come if is anyone come speak
to you even because why you are saying
it to understand why people say that so
what I'm saying to what did you go said
so far about God Islam Muhammad Mak
sense yeah obviously Mak sense stuff
I've seen I've done similar things
before as well like along the same lines
yeah and I think yeah aldah you should
become Muslim then yeah I think I think
I'll pray and then I'll see yeah I think
I'll try to pray alhamd pray to God open
your heart in but you can take sh then
pray after but what if I take sh and I
don't pray doesn't make any sense
because how you going to pray before sh
is well no but I I pray I can still pray
and I can supplicate supplicate yeah you
can supplicate Allah yeah but you know
what I say to you look why say to want
to bring you back to skepticism so the
blame word
skepticism the blame word one like for
example the blame word one when we know
there's some some topic there's only two
options and I say no no no it could be
the other options it could be this we
don't know it it's called scism which
lead you to craziness to to Insanity you
understand that's why you know believe
in God believeing this this universe
have Creator is so clear but because in
the western World been raised with
skepticism the blame worthy one you
start doubting other options it could be
this could it's clear everything
indicate towards intelligence Creator
creator with wisdom I accept that let
alone the proof that is coming from the
Quran and the prophecy of prophet
Muhammad he understand and another one
another prophecy that Prophet Muhammad
mentioned said he said it will come a
time yes in Muslim when the Arabs they
stop using the Beast as a the c as a as
a riding Beast imagine the Arabs that's
the that's the only thing they use as a
riding Beast they will stop using a camo
in another narration he said they will
use something like a
box and the school has explained it mean
the cars now if you go to AR they don't
use C anymore they use cars yeah so
there's many proes why Islam is a truth
you know
overwhelming yeah I mean yeah obviously
I like try study like I said you look I
would love for you to become Muslim to
be number five today but you know if you
want to say go home raise your hand to
God and you know because before it's too
late cuz one one day you're going to die
one day you know that's what I'm saying
you never know maybe today you never
know may Allah may Allah save you yet
but raise your hand man like I said to
you there overwhelming proof why Islam
is a truth you know even take you to the
Christianity because you came from
Christianity background yeah oh your
family in the Bible in the Old Testament
there is a prophecy about Prophet
Muhammad
yeah proph about Prophet Muhammad yes so
this another proof that how a man
something came 1,000 years before
Prophet Muhammad and it speaks about him
and guess what Allah mentioned in the
Quran that your name or the scripture is
been mentioned in the previous scripture
that's too many proofs oh because um the
something about the Bible it says um
that don't believe anything anyone who
comes after me or something like that
yeah Jesus said that but Jesus Muhammad
he's speaking about Paul cuz Paul
came yeah
paulos teach of Jesus this called Isaiah
42 behold my servant whom I uphold my
elect one in whom my soul Delight I have
put my spirit upon him I will bring
forth Justice to the Gentiles Jesus said
this no no this Isaiah 42 in the Old
Testament in the Old Testament yeah Old
Testament yeah Isaiah gen is a non Jews
yeah so this Prophet is coming servant
of God Gentiles also watch
this let the village that K inhabit who
K if you go to Genesis
2513 from God the prophet and this were
the names the names of the sons of isma
then according to their generation the
first born of ISB then
who sorry mishma no no this one this one
k kada okay K is the son of is and this
Prophet that is
coming and this Prophet is coming let
the village that K inhabits let the
inhabit of silah sing silah is a
mountain in Saudi you can Google it the
mountain of silah so the point here is
this prophecy doesn't not fit no one
except Prophet Muhammad and the prophet
is that where
he he came from yeah so Prophet
Muhammad's name
abdah fromr
from so so now there's a prophecies
about the future and a prophet there's
there's a passage in the Quran which
mentioned to Prophet Muhammad you
scripture is been mentioned in the
previous scripture now Prophet Muhammad
cannot write this one it's 1,000 years
before him you understand yeah but then
okay that's too many proof
yeah it's overwhelming proofs you know
if you close your eyes and you say where
is the sun you will never be able to see
it no no I I see inah like I say I would
love for you to become Muslim now about
if you want to go home and pray to God
say oh God Open My Heart To Your Truth
let me give you something here let me
give you this nice
de you have any question oh here this a
nice book this book Baba this book
mallah
hopefully you benefit from it do you
read yeah soor I read yeah you read
I read sometimes yeah read stuff yeah
this very interesting about history
about religion I think you will like it
inah you know the problem that now with
our young Brothers I mean the advice I
can give you is that we are too busy in
social media and social media what is
doing to us is making our Focus very
short yeah yeah before we used to watch
YouTube now now we turn to 5 Seconds
yeah Tik tok's crazy and people taking
videos out of context clip but the point
here is me I love I love read
even PDFs I like to read PDFs but I
prefer a book like my night time is for
me to sit at home have my tea and my
book in my hand I like to read I have a
big library at home I have over maybe
bro I have over a thousand book aldah
stud I love reading books you know
because knowledge is in the books yeah
you have any question uh yeah no I have
no more questions thank you very much
you're welcome I'm here we we have every
Friday usually on the other side okay if
you want to have more discussion you can
come back inah okay Brothers may Allah
bless
you